[Music]
I think there's this tendency to think
that technology can save us or that
technology is going to be uncomplicated
when it saves us and if you look at
every technological innovation they've
all been really complicated and so we
can't wait for automation to save us we
can't wait for technology to solve
climate change these are these are
political problems the the reduction in
the quality of work is a political
problem that requires a political
solution there's no app for forming a
union in your workplace there's no app
for raising the minimum wage where you
live or raising taxes on rich people
these are the things we need to work
toward and we can't wait for or hope for
or expect that technology is going to
offer us any solution when it never has
before if you're millennial one of the
things that will probably make you
really mad is that when our parents were
protesting the Vietnam War Americans
under 45 outnumbered Americans older
than 45 by two-to-one so when they were
electing JFK and when they were
protesting the Vietnam War they could
elect politicians to put them in power
whereas now as the population has gotten
older it's now almost 50/50 half the
populations under 45 and half the
population is over 45 and what that
means is there's never been an American
generation that has held on to power as
it aged the way that the Boomers have
the boomers are still in power they
still out vote us they don't outnumber
us anymore but because they vote at
greater rates they still do outnumber us
in power the median member of Congress
is 59 that is bad the if you're a
millennial you've spent your entire life
being told by everybody from teachers to
MTV that you should vote you've also
experienced voting getting harder the
lines are getting longer and especially
in poorer areas this is being done
deliberately voter ID laws are coming up
everywhere it's getting harder to vote
so yes it's important for us to vote
but it's also really important that when
we get into power we need to make it
easier to vote I live in a state where
you receive your ballot in the mail
there's no waiting in line you get it
you have two weeks the postage is paid
and you send it back we have way higher
turnout especially in primaries and a
lot of other states do if you're working
two jobs it makes perfect sense for you
not to vote of course you're not gonna
stand in line for three hours so I think
what needs to be our generational
project is finding all of these
procedures and making them easier it's
not just a matter of voting we need to
vote and then we need to make it easier
for the next generation to vote
[Music]